Cuz remember Yeah. Is this a Yes. Let me
tell you why. Let me tell you why.
Putting two shapes together is a
contradiction according to Ali Dawa and
our friend Sam. So break down how this
is a contradiction.
Can you do me a favor and try to put the
square in the triangle?
The square. You said it's a
contradiction. You said put the square
in the triangle. You said it's a
contradiction. Put the square in the
triangle. You said, "Wait, can I try the
triangle?" This is This is your toy. Let
me have the triangle. No, no, no. Put
the Look, put the triangle. Look, look,
look. It still doesn't fit. It still
doesn't fit. It still doesn't fit. So,
now what? Now, now hold on a second,
guys. Why is the triangle not fitting in
the square? Cuz it's not a square.
Because nature exactly, thank you, my
friend. Now, the square.
Why isn't it working? Let me try here.
Ah. Oh, let me try the triangle for
God's sake. Let me see.
It's still not working. But let me try
the tri. Okay.
My argument is the following. Guys, I
have never said you can't bring a
triangle and square. It is absolute
stupidity to say this is an
impossibility. How could this be an
impossibility or contradiction? My
argument was the following. There are
three types of existence. An
impossibility. Exactly. Can I hold this?
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to Isa.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said, "Charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now."
your toys in your ham shopping bag.
Count out your toys. So guys, out your
dollies.
You're supposed to say that before you
read the Quran. Sorry. Before you read
the Quran, you're supposed to say that.
Yeah. No, no, I'm just saying it. I feel
like saying it. And it's not, you know,
you don't always need to do that before.
You don't need to do that before the
Quran, by the way. You don't need to.
See, you need to you study Islam a lot.
Now guys, this is the first time I am
buying my Christian friend a present.
Now, why did I buy him a present? I know
there's a lot of people jealous. David
Wood Apus, he became a Christian once he
raised £100,000. AP, come on. Put his
wife He put his wife in a hijab. The man
put his wife in a hijab. He said,
"Listen, we're making some good money
here. £100,000. You better put that
hijab on." So, we don't blame that. But
I'm sure he Christ came to him in a
vision like it did with
Paul. I even wrapped it up
myself in pepper
pig. I had to even though pork is haram.
Do you eat pork? No. Oh, that's You know
what? Big up big up to no logic for
that. From me to you. My name is Avery.
What's your name? A. I call you no
logic. No, call me A. Wait,
we would have. No, we would have, but I
heard that you condone ripping the
Quran. I I said under the right
circumstances. Interesting. I believe in
no circumstances I would ever rip up the
Bible in no circumstances. But it's nice
that you follow Jesus. If somebody if if
somebody rips up the Bible, I will stop
them. I got you. I will stop them. But
if if somebody rips up the Quran in
return, would you would would you blame
them? If someone rips up a If somebody
rips If somebody rips up the Quran in
response to somebody ripping the Bible,
would you would you condone that? Two
wrongs don't make a right. Allah says in
the Quran, would you blame them? Repel?
Yes. Oh, especially if he's a Muslim.
For example, if if someone rips up if
someone rips up the Quran,
sorry. Hey, hey, you okay? Yeah. Yeah.
Water. I got water. I'm okay. Thank you.
If someone rips up the Quran, bro, you
need some water. No, no,
no. It's anyone. You okay? Yeah, I got
Hey fever, that's why. But it's fine.
Hey guys, pray for Ali. Don't touch him.
I think water will be enough. Keep keep
give keep give keep give keep give keep
that yourself. Now if someone rips up
the Quran and in return somebody rips up
the Bible he's going against the Quran
because the Quran says I know repel evil
with that which is good. Uh-huh. So with
us, we don't believe two two wrongs make
a right. I know. I know. Now my thing is
this to you.
Yesterday we had I would have a nice
cordial discussion with you because you
came to me all polite and this that. But
the thing is your reality is not that.
If your reality was that, bro, let me be
honest with you. I have a nice civilized
discussion. That's how I am. No, you're
not. You condone ripping the Quran. I
condone I condemn anyone that rips the
Bible. Not that we have anyways. So
anyways, you are as bad as the ones that
rip. But this is my point though. My
point is is that your Quran says do not
mock those who invoke other than Allah,
right? Lest they will mock Allah in
return. So what I'm saying is is that
the Quran warns Muslims of provoking the
people to certain actions when they mock
Yes. Right. Exactly. So what I'm saying
is is as a Muslim if you see that a
Christian responds right in let's say
ripping the Quran or mocking Muhammad or
or Allah. Okay. Why they responding?
Because the because the Muslim is
cursing God or cursing Jesus, cursing
Holy Spirit. Which Muslim curses Jesus?
Uh there's Muslims like Aki X shadow AX
he says what? Uh oh I I'm not going to
repeat it. But what he does I'll tell
you what he does. He he has a he has a
picture where he puts Jesus on a on a
cross in a clown uniform. That's what he
does. We believe Jesus is a prophet. How
could you? I know. But Exactly. That's
my point. Our Muslims know we could we
can't insult Jesus cuz we believe it all
the time. No. Again to us if they do it
for you to insult Jesus is it takes out
the form of Islam. Look Ali, I know what
you're saying. But what you're saying is
no, no, no, you're being slightly
because you condemn, you condone the
ripping of the Quran as Muslim, look
Muslims. Listen, we Muslims are the
whatever you want to call it, the
terrorists and we are antichrist. But
for some odd reason, for some odd
reason, we as Muslims, we don't live the
Bible. Yeah, we don't stepping on the
all the time. What are you talking
about? Who steps on the Bible? Look, I
tell you, Aki X is a is a Muslim. Who is
Aki X? I don't know who Aki X is. You
ask me who. I'm giving you an example.
No, no one second. You don't know him.
No, no, no, no, no, no. One second. Tell
me he ripped up in the Bible and put him
in the toilet. Tell me any brother in
the da scene who is known that there's
ever touch the Bible knows him. I repeat
again. I repeat, you're not going to get
me some random guy somewhere. You ask me
who Aki X. Oh, I'm going to Aki Christ.
Listen to me. Has there been me,
Muhammad, hijab, um
Hashim? No, no, no. Has any of them ever
disrespected the Bible by ripping it?
Nothing I've seen. Not that I've seen.
That doesn't matter. You point proven.
No, let me answer you. Let me say it.
That's why. Let me say something. Okay.
You condone the ripping of the Quran.
Hold on a second. You should be ashamed
of yourself. I know. You got to let me
talk to Let me finish and we can talk.
You should be ashamed of yourself. You
all say you follow Christ. Yeah. Jesus
is love. Yeah. Love your enemies. Yeah.
Turn down the cheek. Yeah. Shame on you
all. You know why? Because we as Muslims
are the closest to you guys. We are the
closest to you guys. The Jews, what did
the Jews say? Jesus is burning in his
own feces. What do they say about Mary?
She is an adulterer. What do we say? We
renovate. We honor them. And what do you
do? Your number one public enemy is who?
Islam. Not that we're phased by you
guys. Your arguments a week like we saw
yesterday. We saw your arguments a week,
bro. It's finished. But yes. So now tell
me I'm respond. Yes. Respond to what I
said. Why you condone the ripping of the
Quran? Yeah. So at first Ali dawa, you
said who? Who? Show me anyone. and I
named you a Muslim. I gave you one by
name and now you shift the goalpost to
well, okay, well, give me somebody from
the Dawa scene that's well known. You
switched the goalpost to that. All you
asked for at first was a Muslim that did
did what? Uh, for example, so I'm
showing you did. But now you switched it
to, oh well, who's popular among the
Muslims who does that? That doesn't
matter. If you got Muslims, like for
example, I deal with Muslims all the
time. I think more than what you do, cuz
I do the, you know, debate every day. So
I see what Muslims do. And if I see
Muslims be disrespectful to the Holy
Spirit, disrespectful to Jesus. And it
garers a response to Christians, I have
no problem with a Christian responding
to Muslim action by even if even if it's
ripping the Quran only if it's cursing
God. If you if they curse God, ripping
the Quran is on the table for them. I
won't blame them for doing that. Now,
however, I will never say or giving
encourage and I would condemn if
somebody is going around ripping Qurans
just for the sake of it. with under
under no um you like for no reason.
Okay. You know what I'm saying? So,
nobody should be doing that. But if
people are cursing, if Muslims are
cursing the Holy Spirit, cursing our
God, then they get what they do. They
they get what comes of it. No problem.
One second. You said no problem. You
don't have a problem. Are they good and
bad Muslims? Sure. Are they good and bad
Christians? Yeah. If I was to say to
you, if I said any Muslim, that would be
silly of me. If I said that, did I say
Muslim? You said Muslim in general. If I
said Muslims in general, I'm wrong. I
said to you, of course, there's Muslims
do bad and good stuff. We know Muslims
that do crazy stuff. We know Christians
that do crazy stuff. My argument was
this. You are a a person that is
following Christianity. I am someone
who's in, as you know, we do da'a. No
one in the da scene has ever ripped the
Bible out. Now, let's go with argument
sake. Do you follow Christ? Yep. Do you?
I believe I do. But one sec. We'll come
to that. Okay. Don't worry. We're here
right now. We're going to one second.
Okay. What would Jesus do? In in what
regard? argue. Let's go for argument
sake. Muslims, they rip the Bible. They
rip the Bible. Would Would Jesus do the
same back? I don't know. Maybe I I think
actually what Jesus would do, he would
go up to the Muslim and call him, which
was which was your camera? Which one was
your camera? Is that what this is? What
he'll do? What what Jesus would do is
he'll go to a Muslim. He'll go to a
Jesus. He'll go up to the Muslim and
he'll call him a snake and a viper and a
hypocrite because they claim to follow
him and then they point the finger at
others while they reject who he is and
reject his words. Yeah. So that's what
he'll do. Okay. So did Jesus say turn
the other cheek? In what in what regard?
In what context? Oh, there's context
now. Of course. Okay. Interesting. All
right. Jesus is not a pacifist. Okay.
Ah. He teaches mercy rather than, you
know, Christians. He's not a passive.
Listen carefully to what he's saying.
Yeah. I don't want to hear anymore. We
love you. If you slap us, we'll turn the
other cheek. Uh-uh. He's just abrogated
that. Nothing. Don't no. So you're
telling me, hey, Jesus. One second.
Jesus is walking. He sees a Muslim. We
don't. We as Muslims in the public
scene, we don't do that. Rip up the
Quran. Do what? Ripping up the Bible.
Yes, you do. Okay. Which one of the
influencers? Which one of the Muslim
influencers has ever publicly ripped the
Bible? What does that got to do? You're
you're saying you said no Muslim goes
around and publicly ripped up the Bible.
That's what you said. Stop saying no
Muslim. Stop saying that. Which Muslim
public influencer in the da scene as a
role model has ripped the Bible? Role
model. What? That's all subjective,
dude. That's all subjective. So, look,
if I give you a Muslim that does that
publicly, you're going to say, "Oh,
well, he's irrelevant." No, no, no. One
second. Can you tell me one? A X. Who
the hell is Exactly. Who the hell is
AKX? David the Christ follower. Uh,
somewhere around there. Come on, my
friend. There's no one there. Point
proven. Now, what would Jesus do? What
would Jesus do? He'll call you a snake
and a viper and a hypocrite. Would Jesus
rip the Quran instead? I don't know. He
wouldn't. So you don't follow Jesus.
Now, now let's come to the chase cuz
today is his birthday, ain't it? Okay.
Can you open your present, please? No,
not yet. Now, come on, man. It's a
present. Cuz it's the whole point of it,
man. Bro, bro, I don't buy my kids toys
from Hamley's. Man spent £30. What is
Ham's? I roughed it up myself. It's an
expensive toy store. A toy store. They
said to me, "What age group are you
looking for?" I said, "The
three-year-old."
Why a three-year-old? Open it. Why not a
Open it?
Six. Oh, man. Why don't you? All right,
let's see.
[Music]
You said you wrapped it yourself. Yeah,
I wrapped it myself. Look, you're a
guest. You came all the way from
America. We need to give you a gift. I
see. And now look,
bro, it delayed it delayed me 1 hour. I
had to go to Hamley's. I had to buy a
gift wrap. I had to wrap it up myself.
A puzzle. No, no, no. Where's your
camera? What? What? What? I know you
guys are jealous cuz you didn't get it.
You You haters.
Now we need to open it. Do you want to
open it? Should we open it? Go ahead.
We'll open it together. One thing. One
thing, please. How is this? No. No. Show
this. Show me the
camera. He's moving. He moved it. He
moved it. He moved it.
It's good, DJ. It's good, DJ. It's good.
evidence.
It's good. He's chill. He's chilling
touching my
side. It's all right.
No, no, no, no, no, no. It's just one
thing. No, I'm not. I'm going to walk.
I'm going to walk. Leave the circle.
Leave a circle. Leave the circle. Leave
a circle. Leave the circle. Leave the
circle. Cuz they were having a peaceful
discussion between you and I. Leave the
circle. And now he's claiming it. Leave
the circle. Leave the circle. Why did
you lie? No, no. Last year I asked him,
you always claim that the Quran affirms
the Bible. He denied. He said, "I did
not make that claim." And now look, he's
claiming it. Please show I'm going to
Anyway, don't touch it. Look, last year
he said to me, "Bro, somebody condones
the Quran." Wait, wait, wait. Please
wait. Listen, double standard. This guy
is a liar. Look, I'm going to expose his
lies. Look, look, watch out. I have that
video. It's on Tik Tok everywhere. Lost
logic. Last year I asked him you made a
claim which is the Quran affirms the
Bible and now he came to me he said I
did not make that claim and now he's
claiming it and when I asked him to
describe according to he couldn't
describe
[Music]
it in
jail in jail what's in jail in jail
what's
What's
in what's
[Music]
in
sie a
No, no. He said the
Bible again. He said the Bible confirms
I mean the Quran confirms the Bible.
When I asked him to
describe according to Islam, he can't.
And he said I did not make that claim.
No, he did not make that claim. I
understand you
made
sos you exposing that's it.
I'm going to expose all your videos. I'm
going to edit all your videos to expose
you. I'm going to edit all your videos
to expose you.
He said, "I didn't make a stopping
my stopping my
Let's back up. Everybody back up. Let's
get some space." Let's give us some
Christians. Give us some space. You
might run. What? Okay. I'm getting back.
context. What's that? Hello guys.
Hello guys. Can we Can we have water? I
invited you to this party. I don't want
to kick you guys out.
Now, yesterday we had an argument, a
debate, and my argument was from
contingency.
That's That's called the nerve laugh.
Nervous love. I don't know. He's like,
he's like, "Oh, no. I don't know what's
coming out." Now, since I
realized no logic, doesn't know his
shapes. I bought him,
bro. I spent £30 on this. Relax.
Okay.
[Music]
We're all together.
Person number two. second person. Second
person or the trinity. Can you get the
triangle out? Yeah. Okay.
Cuz I thought to myself, you know what?
When you talk about triangles and
squares, you hand me you need to have it
in front of you. Sometimes it doesn't
make sense. We'll call this the Holy
Spirit, but we'll come to it later.
Now, one second.
What shape is this? He gave you a gift
for the Holy Spirit. I have I have to
Don't blame me. Don't blame me.
Yesterday he goes, "You can bring the
shapes together." We're going to
demonstrate it now. Now the triangle.
What does it say? We're about to see
just how dumb this is. Yes, you're
right. We're about to see just how dumb
this is. We literally are now. So now
I'm I'm about to I'm about to I'm about
to indulge you. I'm indulge you. What
What does that mean? It means I'm going
to entertain you. So no, I'm
entertaining. Yeah, you are
entertaining. I know you're
entertaining. Yes. Yes. Okay. Now, so
when you have when you have this, watch
this. Yes. This, ladies and gentlemen,
this is a triangle, right?
No. Come on. This yeah, this lad. Hold
on. Let me hold it. Okay. But it's going
to fall out. Oh, okay. Yeah, that's why.
Yeah. Yeah. So, this, ladies and
gentlemen, Yeah. is a square. Okay.
Okay. Really? Small. Okay. A square. Are
the squares next to each other? Yeah. Is
this a contradiction?
Now, now, now listen carefully. Yeah.
Now, now watch how they're going to go
dead silent like this. Now, can someone
Can someone hold this for me?
[Music]
Someone hold. Can someone hold this for
me? Hold this for me. Now, yesterday I
made an argument for contingency. I said
there are three types of existence. The
first existence is what? A triangle
square. He's going to do that. Stop
trying to jump out the pot. Is it a
contradiction? Hold on. Hold on.
Triangle square. Now, can you have a
triangle square? Can you have a triangle
square? Is this a contradiction if
they're next to each other?
Okay. Now, if they are next to each
other, how many shapes are there?
There's two. Okay. Is that a
contradiction? One second. How many How
many natures? How many? One second.
Jesus. Okay. Is he one person? One
person in What do you mean in what? In
two. No, two natures are in one person.
Christians, you've gone silent. Two
natures, one person. No. Oh, two two
natures, one person. One person. Okay.
So, now is this a contradiction? This is
human sign. Yeah. Is this a
contradiction? Yes. Because I said, can
you have a triangle square? This is a
triangle. This is a square. If you put
them together, you have a house that
falls apart. Because I said there's the
divine nature of Jesus that you guys
believe in. Let's call him the triangle.
And there is the human nature that you
believe. There are two persons. Person
one. Two person. Look, person one
second. You're not
even one second. Triangle. Triangle.
Triangle. Let the people decide.
Triangle is a divine nature. Correct.
Let's make the triangle divine nature.
Sure. Okay. The divine nature. Look
guys, look. Look, look. Yeah. Look. The
divine nature. You know when Coco loves,
he's in big trouble. Now, the human
nature is square. Yeah. Yeah. How many
persons? One. All right. Alhamdulillah.
Orthodox Muslim. This was for you.
Alhamdulillah. Now, now this is the
human nature. Person one. This is the
human nature and the divine nature. You
cannot when you bring them together,
it's a contradiction. You cannot have a
triangle square. Meaning when you bring
them together you have how many shapes?
Two. He said how many persons are there?
One. So that is my argument. You can't
have the human nature and the god nature
in together because that means you have
a triangle square. A square has four
sides. A triangle has sides. How many
sides a triangle have? You don't know.
Three. Triangle square. You can talk.
How many sides? Three. Three. How many
square? Four. Can you bring them
together? No. Why? It's an
impossibility. This is the reason why.
Look guys, he goes, "You can bring them
next to each other." That's not my
argument. My argument is the following.
There's one nature that is human. There
is one nature that is God. You are a
neto. If you say there are two two
persons, then you are committing heresy.
You're right. Yes. So I repeat again,
this is the human nature. This is the
god nature. Yes. Can you bring them
together? Thank you. Simple question.
All right. My turn now. All right. So,
Ali Dawa. Um, I thank you for bringing
the shapes cuz we needed your help to
demonstrate just for you. Where's the
thing? Yeah, thank you. I know what
you're saying. Okay, good. I know what
you're saying. You feel me? You feel
like just really quick cuz you you
talked about notorianism. Do you know
what that is exactly? That they believe
in two persons. Very good. Yes. So,
notorianism is belief in two persons.
Yes. Now, be honest with me. Have I ever
said two persons? No. That's why I asked
you. Very good. All right. Thank you.
Thank you. All right. So it's pretty
clear Ali knows that I am not saying
that there are two persons. Exactly. We
are saying that there are two what?
Natures. Very good. Oh, just one second.
So natures and persons are two different
categories. Do we agree? Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Good. So if I say that there's two
natures, I'm not saying there's two
persons. I know. If I say there's two
natures within one person, I'm there's
two different categories. Yeah. All
right. So you said that you're talking
about one nature being the same as the
other. The opposite nature being the
same as the other nature, right? Yes.
Them being together. Okay. Are these
together? Not like that. Are these
together? No, not like that. I'm not
talking about when I put when I bring a
triangle and I bring a square and I
bring it together. How many shapes do
you have? Is this This is two shapes.
Good. Is this a Wait, I answered all
your questions. Remember my turn. Yes. I
bring them together. Are they Are they
together? Yes. Is this a contradiction?
They are two different shapes, too. Is
this a two shapes? I I Thank you. How
many shapes you have? Wait, I look I do.
It's my turn. Yes, but you're asking me.
I know. Don't ask me. Is this a
contradiction? Don't talk. You know
what? I'll go around. Go, go, go. Sam,
is this a contradiction? No, he said
don't talk. I'm talking. Okay. So, Sam
says yes. Sam says yes. It is a
contradiction. So putting one shape and
another shape and putting it side by
side together. This ladies and gentlemen
is a contradiction according to the
Muslims. Do you agree?
Do you agree? No. No. I say you got to
answer me. Can I ask you? Cuz Yeah. Is
this a Yes. Let me tell you why. Okay.
Putting two shapes together is a
contradiction according to Ali Dawa and
our friend Sam. So, break down how this
is a contradiction.
Can you do me a favor and try to put the
square in the triangle?
The square. You said it's a
contradiction. Put the square in the
triangle. You said it's a contradiction.
Put the square in the triangle. You said
Wait, can I try the triangle? This is
This is your toy. Let me have the
triangle. No, no, no. Put the Put the
triangle. Look, look, look. It still
doesn't fit. It still doesn't fit. It
still doesn't fit. So, now what? Now,
now hold on a second, guys. Why is the
triangle not fitting in the square? Does
it not have a square? Because it's a
different nature. Exactly. Thank you, my
friend. Now, the
square. Why isn't it working? Let me try
here. Ah,
let me try the triangle. For God's sake,
let me
seem. It's still not working. But let me
try the tri.
Okay. My argument is the following,
guys. I have never said
You can't bring a triangle and square.
It is absolute stupidity to say this is
an impossibility. How could this be an
impossibility or contradiction? My
argument was the following. There are
three types of existence. An impossible
exist. Exactly. Can I hold this? The
Lord's going to have mercy on you, my
friend. You need it today. Yeah. Now,
brothers and sisters, impossible
existence, possible existence, and
necessary existence. I said an
impossible existence is what? Something
that don't exist. No, no, no. Triangle
square. Can you have a triangle square,
Christians? I thought so. They know.
They know you cannot have a triangle
because a triangle is three sides. A
square is four sides. He said, "But you
can bring them together." I said, "I
have no problem. It looks like a house,
but I'm destroying the house." You know
why? Because you can't have a triangle
square. I got you now. One second. Just
one second. Now, I'm going to We'll let
the people decide. It's bad. It's good.
It's medium. I want it well done. Medium
rare. How you like your steak? No
problem. Now brothers and sisters, human
nature is person. Look, human nature and
it's not personal and you have God
nature. The human nature is totally
opposite. You know why? Cuz my
definition of a dependent being that's
contingent is what? It depends on
something else for survival. It can be
any other way. And it is composed of
pieces. The my definition for the
necessary independent being. It is
independent. It is not composed of
pieces and it cannot be any other way.
That's the reason why I repeat again.
You don't have to. Look, you can keep
the toy. It's for you. I want to show
you this. Look, look, it's a
three-year-old. If I go to my daughter
and I say, "What is a square?" She say,
"Dad, it's four sides." And I say, "What
is a triangle?" Say, "Dad, three sided."
If I say to her, "What is a triangle
square?" She say, "What?" So, I'm asking
a simple question. Can you have Yes, I'm
I know. Can you have a triangle square
when you admit it is an impossible
existence? Well, let's see. Let's see.
Jesus. I got you. All right. So, Ali
Dawa. I need you to talk. Sorry. Where's
my water?
Where? Where?
Someone took my water. Do you need
water? Yeah.
If you go in my Okay, that's fine. All
right. So, Ali, instead of you being
kind to me, Instead of you being kind to
me with water, condemn those
who hold on a second. So, Alawa, watch
this. Ladies and gentlemen, watch this.
It's going to be super funny. Alidawa,
what shape is this? I'll be finding you
now cuz it Yeah, it is. What shape is
this? Triangle. A square. This is a
square. Yes. Okay. What shape is in the
square? Triangle. Wait. Yeah.
Now, you just told me that a triangle
cannot be in a square, but you just said
that this is a square that has a
triangle in it. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
I'm a little confused. Repeat, repeat.
So, wait. I just want to know. I just
want to know. Since this is a square
and this inside the square is a
triangle, is this a contradiction?
Yes or no? Can you Can you Wait, wait,
wait. I just I cuz I'm about to make my
point. Yes or no? Can Can you This is a
square, my friend. There's triangle,
square, star, circle, and pent. Oh, it
has multiple shapes within the square.
Is there multiple gods? I said, can you
have now quick
question? Yes or no? One second. Your
Christian follower is not going to help
you today. Was it a contra? Let me tell
you why. No. No. Check this out. How
many sides? Is it No. Look, it's a yes
or no. No, it's not contradiction. All
right. So, now let me continue. Let me
continue. I only want Come back later.
That's fine. Okay, that's fine. So, it's
not a contradiction that this is a
square and within the square there is a
triangle, but you tried to make this
whole point that it was a contradiction
earlier. It's done and over with. I I'm
I'm glad you bought this because this is
actually the appropriate toy that I can
use to demonstrate how dumb your
argument is. This is appropriate. This
is it was a beautiful gift. Now, to
continue this beautiful gift to continue
this, let me show you. Now let's let's
let's trade in the categories and the
and the and the characteristics now.
Okay. Now talking about persons versus
natures. Christ one person has two
natures. I'm not saying that Jesus is
two persons. That is notorianism like
you said earlier. But now when I say
this I'm not in heresy. So stop arguing
against the heresy and argue against me.
Interesting. Okay. So one person two
natures. How is it a contradiction?
I mean I just I just you know sometimes
they say if your enemy is making a fool
out of yourself just let them talk.
That's why they say let him talk.
Orthodox Muslim brother make a field day
with this. Did you just see that? And
you know what's funny? The Christians
are cheering. They don't even know what
just happened. We just want to respond.
They didn't even realize. That's why you
know what you do? You just like you know
what? No problem. Did you see what he
said? You haven't bro please don't cut
it. Don't say the editor made the
mistake here, please. He goes, "This is
a square and there is a triangle
inside." Guys, guys, he got the board.
He goes, "This is a square, four sides,
and there's a triangle inside." So that
means his argument is proven, brothers
and sisters. What was the argument? That
the fact that there's a triangle in a
square. And what is that? What is my
argument? If that is your argument, then
why did you say it is an impossible
existence to have a triangle square? No,
that's You just said that shows you
missed the argument. That's not the
argument. So, one second. Is it an
impossible existence or impossible? Cuz
he just said, "What?" One second. Look,
guys. He knows what just happened. And
this is why the Christians are gone. It
shows that you missed the argument
again. Now, let me tell you why. No. One
second. Let me finish. Let me finish.
But let me finish. Okay. You came in
with a chef outfit and I'm going to cook
you. Now, check this out. Yeah. He said,
"Guys, check this out." Often, of
course, is watching this. He's laughing
his head off. Now, I go to him. There
are three types of existence, guys.
impossible existence, dependent
existence and necessary existence. He
admitted can you have a triangle square?
It is an he said it is an impossible
existence. Do you know what he just did
now? He went back on his way and said no
square triangle and the Christians went
you miss you you could miss the entire
argument my friend look look can you
have a tri look listen triangle square
yes or no this is the point this is a
square right this is a square right yes
that's one shape right yes is there a
triangle in the square but I didn't say
can you have just answer is there a
triangle in the square how many shapes
is that there's two shapes is that a
contradiction no thank you but I didn't
say that so I didn't but I didn't say I
didn't say look listen I didn't say what
was my question listen I didn't question
you're you're asking can a question
listening what was your question is can
a triangle be the square no that's what
no listen to me there you go there you
go you're saying can the triangle be the
square my friend you don't even know how
to cook anywhere in a chef no you don't
you now guys it's
touch it's not a contradiction what did
I ask I said there's three types of
possibilities existence what was the
first
Uh something that doesn't exist.
Exactly. Good. So now I give the example
of what doesn't exist. Wait. How is
non-existence a type of exist? Wait,
wait, wait. No, no, that's my point. Now
I asked you. I asked you, did I say
anywhere, can you have, you know, that's
a problem? Awkward, you know, awkward
nervous laugh that wasn't even telling
me about it. Oh, yeah. He's the master
of this. Yeah. Yeah. Bro, Orthodox
Muslim knows a nervous laugh when he
see. No, no, no. Orthodox Muslim know
listen to me.
I asked you. I said, "Yeah, can you have
a triangle square?" What was my answer?
It was no. Okay. What did you just
demonstrate now? I demonstrated that
there's two shapes. Okay. Was that my
question? No. Then why are you
demonstrating this? Because you're I'm
showing you my position. My position.
Listen, my my position. Look, if you're
saying, "Can there be a triangle
square?" Basically, I'm say there's one
there's one. Then there's no the answer
is no. No. No. Pay attention, bro. Save
for the people in the back. Can you pay
attention? Can you pay attention? No, it
can't. So, pay attention. Did you hear
it, Christian? Pay attention. No. N O.
Pay attention. Okay. So, with your
position, can there be a a square
triangle? That would be one shape that
is a square triangle. One shape, right?
There's a shape called square triangle.
I know. That's what I'm saying. Then
what would you demonstrate to I'm
demonstrating to you? You made a fool
out yourself. And the cherry cherry.
You're nervous. Now you're panicking. He
doesn't know the Now you're panicking
now. Now you're panicking. Okay, I'll
stop. I'll stop panicking. I'm going to
stop panicking. Hey guys, support the
dollar, man. He's in panic mode. Yeah.
Look, this is what it is. Teach people
how to pray salah, guys. This is what it
is, Ali. This is what it is, Ali. Hold
on really quick. What we on? You're
getting distracted. You're getting
distracted. Getting distracted for some
donations. I know like Jesus. Got you.
So, when you say triangle square, you're
asking is there one shape that could be
both a triangle and a square at the same
time? Can they? Right. And the answer is
no. My position is is not that Jesus has
one nature that is mixed with human and
divine. My argument is my position is
that Jesus has two natures. One divine,
one human and they're united in the
person. They don't intermingle. They're
not mixed. Okay. Divine. Divine. Finish.
Let me finish. And human. Let me finish.
How many? How many? How many?
Finish. Finish. Finish. Finish. Finish.
Thank you. I appreciate it. So, what you
need to deal with is my actual position.
I'm not saying that there's one nature
that's mixed. I'm saying there's two ma
natures that are united in one person.
So just like with this I demonstrated to
you that a square can be with a circle
or a a triangle. They can be united next
to each other but it's not and it's not
a contradiction. Just like you
acknowledge this is a square and this is
a triangle in the square. They're united
but it's not a contradiction. You
understand? You finished? Did you did
you get the you finished? You get the
illustration kind of. Yeah. You
finished? Okay. Okay. Okay. So, if I say
that, wait. If I say there's two
natures, is that a contradiction? Huh?
Yes. Let me tell you how. If I say
there's two shapes, is that is that a
contradiction? Well, we we'll wrap this
up once and for all. Here's the
uppercut.
Here is the uppercut.
This is triangle. We call it the divine
nature.
He's preparing for the upper cut. You
know, in boxing, we do boxing back. Keep
the butt warm up. Yeah. Get your guards
up, mate. Okay. This is the divine
nature. Correct, guys? Christians, can
we affirm it, please? Coco can have a
yes. Thank you. Divine nature. This is
the human nature. Correct.
How many shapes do I have in my hand?
Two. How many shapes? Two. Two. He's
saying bring them together.
What is the shape called? It's still a
It's still a square and a triangle. Two
shapes. You still got two shapes. Oh,
what's it? What's it say again? You
still got two shapes. Oh, two shapes.
Oh, but I thought there one person. it.
I'm not saying there's one. I'm not
saying there's two persons. Human
nature. Divine nature. Look at doing
this. What? He's doing this. What is the
shape called? This. What is the shape
called? Oh my gosh. What is the shape
called? Thank you. What is the shape
called? Everybody gets it except you.
Listen. Listen, big man. What shape is
this? Listen, I need you guys to donate
to Muhammad Hijab's hotel fund. This is
this the human nature the divine divine
nature when you bring them together what
is this shape called?
Thank you. A triangle square. How many
shapes? Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah the h. And now I'm going
to talk to you guys about
the oneness of God. Talk about we don't
believe in any of the look. We don't
need look for tohed. underneath triangle
square the triangle means a square is
triangle one second where's the thing
one second it's present the square is in
the triangle and there's a star brother
alhamdulillah can wait can we talk about
let's talk about now brothers and
sisters let me just talk about here I
use the board one second now brothers
and sisters for you don't need no board
all you need is the oneness of god now
brothers and sisters
we talked about impossible existence you
know why I did this for offer of Muslim.
He need he need to smash you with more
arguments and heresy. Alhamdulillah. Now
you agree with him that Jesus is Yahweh.
Alhamdulillah. Now you agree with that
Jesus is Yahweh existence. Let me finish
now. Do you agree? You agree that you
cannot have an impossible existence.
Look any exist? I don't agree with you.
No, it's fine. It's fine. We'll let the
people decide man. Impossible existence
is nonexistence. That's not a type of
existence. Now brothers and sisters,
that's so stupid. Brothers and sisters,
alhamdulillah, we say what? There is
dependent things. We are all here
depending on who? On God Almighty. Would
you agree? I'm sure the Christians would
agree as well. Do we depend on God? My
Christian friends. Yes. Do we depend on
God? Good. Now, we say that we depend on
the independent being that is not
composed of pieces that can be any other
way. Now, what do we know about that
independent necessary being? Number one,
if the universe is dependent, it's
dependent on who? The independent
creator. I'm not going to call him Allah
for now just so you guys can open your
ears. This independent being, he's the
one who created the universe. That means
he has a will. Let me finish. He has a
will. He We know that we have knowledge
in our universe. He has to be the all
knowing. We know that there is power in
the universe. He has to be the all
powerful. We know that there are bad
things happen in the universe. He has to
be the all wise. So now that independent
being that we all depend on, that we all
depend on, yes, is the one true creator
that we are calling our Christian
brothers and sisters here. I don't hate
you guys. I don't have an animosity
towards you guys. You might with me.
Yes, I don't have that with you. All I'm
saying is this that Allah says in the
Quran, tell the people of the book, can
we come to common terms between us and
you that we worship one true creator?
the one that is the all powerful, not
fully man, fully God, fully hippo, fully
man, none of this. So my message is this
guys, I've demonstrated it here with
patterns. You know why? Because going to
say I've showed you guys and you've seen
it for yourself. So I call you guys to
Islam and if you guys come to Islam and
take your shahada, we have a charity
that teaches you how to pray salah just
like Jesus. And now I'm going to give
the final statements to no logic because
you know why god logic means believe in
one god. A dog logic is that a dog obeys
one master and no logic is as you saw
triangle square inside triangle. The
last word is yours my friend. I hope you
appreciate your gift. Where you going?
I'm here. I'm just you can hold it. I I
guess we're not going to talk about I
guess emotional. Um this this is where
we're at. This is where we're at here
guys. So we saw that u that slow Dawe
here doesn't understand shapes. Um, it's
it's actually ironic because he brought
the perfect gift for an illustration for
what he was missing. And so when we show
what he was missing, he says that
putting two shapes together is a
contradiction.
And he admitted that this is a square
and within it is a triangle. I asked him
if this was a contradiction. He said no,
but then he said yes later on. I don't
know. He brought the gift. He didn't get
it. But that's okay. If we're talking
about like for example um you said that
you don't believe in a god that depends
on anything right if Allah doesn't
depend on anything my question to you is
this if Allah wanted to alawa could
Allah have a son if he wanted to
put last name I want you to talk about
let's talk about last name bro make say
whatever you like so now he don't want
to do it he had all this energy for the
hypoatic union but when it talks
He's ready to go. Just one statement and
you're done. Huh? You're done. Huh? Last
night you got Hallelujah. And tonight
you got Hallelujah.
Ali, you don't want to talk about it.
And and and where's No. Where's your
Where's your body god? You
cannot. Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Brothers and sisters,
it's been emotional and sisters.
Alhamdulillah. We as Muslims, we would
neverate. We would neverate the Bible.
Sorry, let me finish. Yeah. So, you said
that you don't you don't believe in a
dependent God. You can't answer the
question on whether Allah could have a
son or not if you wanted to. Showing
that you're afraid to get into the
discussion of But you're ready to press
the hypoatic union something that you do
not understand fundamentally. But when
we ask simple questions about Allah,
they don't want to talk about him. Why
do they want to talk about Is this your
camera? Why don't y'all want to talk
about Allah? Why don't y'all want to
talk about sahed? I need I need the mic.
I need the Thank you. Thank you.
Why don't you guys want to talk about
Can you guys Muslims in the comment
section? Could Allah have a son if he
wanted to? You tell them. And if he
does, you tell them. Would he need help
to do it? You tell them. Because
according to chapter six in the Quran,
tell them. Allah says, you tell them.
How can I have a son? Yes. When I have
no mates.
So it looks like to me you believe in a
God that's dependent.
He could he could have a son. Oh, no.
But he would. No, don't do that again.
No, Christians, don't do that again.
You're hurting me. In order in order to
have a son, he needs help to do it. So,
by definition, your God is dependent.
Exactly. Al Hallelujah. Alhamdulillah
Yeshua. Leave Islam.
Leave Islam. Leave Islam. Trinity is the
only way that you can know the true God.
We can come to common ground. Know the
true God, the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Alhamdulillah. That's the
true God. Leave Islam. This is false.
All right. Make sure make sure this is
uploaded. Oh, it will be uploaded.
Alhamdulillah. And that gift I paid £30.
You want the bag? Take the bag. Take the
bag. Are you going to throw it away?
You're going to throw it away. Now give
it to me. Now give it to me. I'll give
I'll give it I'll give it to my
daughter. She'll be like, "Dad, that's a
triangle. That's a square." She going to
say, "Yeah, Dad, that's not a
contradiction." I'll say, "Dad, Dad,
that's not a contradiction."
Dad, that's an impossible existence.
Somebody believes it together. Dad,
that's an impossible existence, isn't
it?
Any Christian?
Alhamdulillah.
Ali about No, he doesn't want to.
Doesn't want to debate. Are you going to
debate? Huh? Are you going to debate or
Muslim? He's already I've already
debated him. No, the Christian guy. If
he wants he could come to my channel and
we could talk. No, but he said he said
you're running away. Tell Tell him to
come to my channel. He said you're
running away. I'm live Monday or Friday.
Tell him come. Okay. One second. Where's
Where's your camera? Right here. Nah, I
don't trust your camera. Where's our
camera? Where's Where's our camera?
Tell Orthodox Muslim if he wants to talk
to me, he can come talk to smash this
guy again, dude. Come tell us how Jesus
was in a sense. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah.
You shouldn't give him content. That's
what we agreed.
No, no,
no. I know. I know. I know. I know.
We're live. We're live. We're live.
This guy is
I am a Rever and I was taught how to
pray Salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to is.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said, "Charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now.